hey Paige what's up Damon is this right
okay so I'm about to go to the grocery
store and it looks like it says I need
to get squid pickles and chocolate at
the grocery store yeah did you want
squid pickles no I I wanted squid and
pickles I must have written it down
wrong okay so I think the what we need
to do in order to fix this list and
avoid confusion like this in the future
is is using commas to punctuate a list
because right now this just looks like
like squid pickles which I mean probably
delicious pickled squid yeah robably
delicious um but not what we were
looking to get today right so okay so if
we do if we don't want to get pickled
squid today then we have to put commas
in between the elements of the list
right because this is what commas do the
separate elements of everything so let's
put in those dividers I need to get
squid comma pickles comma and chocolate
at the grocery store exactly okay so we
can punctuate a list by separating out
nouns and I see from this second
sentence here Paige did you give me a
read for that I'm gonna go for a run
read a chapter of my book and go see the
new Colonel Justice movie oh here that's
good so right now it says that but it
could also just be I'm going to go for a
run read a chapter of my book and go see
that you know like there's no it's a
little confusing it's a little confusing
like there could be such a thing as a
run read it probably is you know like
where you go for a jog while holding a
book sounds difficult so we can also use
commas in lists to separate not just
nouns like in this first one but also
verb phrases so I'm going to go for a
run comma read a chapter of my book
comma and go see the new kernel justice
moving perfect cool so that's how you
punctuate a list with commas yeah you
got it you can learn anything Dave it
out
page out